hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen and I'm in my
most Western gear for part three of Back
to the Future if we can take a moment of
silence for the first round of this
filming that would be very nice cuz I
already filmed this episode and realized
I didn't plug in my microphone so
anyways like I said the first time I'm
very excited about this episode honestly
we all know that sequels can sometimes
be disappointing so I keep expecting
these to get worse and worse but I was
not disappointed with this movie so
let's see what I thought Tanner has
never seen everyone online and some
friends of mine were saying that the
movies either hit or missed with number
three and for me it was a total hit
thought it was super fun I don't think I
would have liked it as much if it had
come first I kind of needed the first
two to be kind of just as normal as
time-travel movies can be but then this
one kind of going off the rails of it
was really nice I had a super great time
with it
so of course the movie starts off and
Doc Brown finds a way for Marty to get
back to the 80s and back to his life but
Doc Brown will forever be stuck in the
1800's 1885 so 50s Doc Brown and Marty
find the DeLorean the Doc Brown from the
1800s has hidden for them and they fix
it up and it's all ready to go but then
they find Doc Brown's tombstone and is
dated a week after he wrote the letter
so of course marty has to go back and
save him this movie is already so silly
and so much fun and waited for the other
two and I love it is there a love count
on this episode of probably not I said
love a lot the last episode
love love love anything I love that they
find duck there you go
I love that they fucked up for house
grave because 50s Doc Brown's dog is
lying on it and it's so sweet Ike would
you lie on my grave if I died I'll take
that silence as a yes a really cute part
of Doc Brown's character is that before
they find the grave 50s Doc Brown is
totally chill about living his
retirement out in the 1800s he's like I
think that's gonna be nice I always
wanted to be a cowboy this is gonna be
great at lumpam positivity super cute
totally his character and then of course
when they find the grave he's like okay
well maybe so Marty goes back for him
and he makes it to 1885 and then he's
just casually chased by a bunch of
Native Americans and then soon after by
a bunch of white guys trying to steal
everything from Native Americans then
Marty hurts himself running away from a
bear and that's the first time I've ever
said that sentence and he ends up being
taken care of by his mother and his self
and they're a couple and they're his
great great grandparents
however many greats you understand
distant relatives and they pull the
whole like oh I'm knocked out and she's
like tending to him he's like mom is
that you I just had a crazy dream and
she's like it's not your mom silly and
at this point is like okay well that was
a little repetitive also I didn't really
get I guess there's like a payoff in the
very end with those characters I didn't
really they didn't bring too much for me
uh story wise like they didn't really
bring much of anything to the story for
me they always showed up I was like oh
yeah they're here because they have to
have other people from other time zones
that are the same characters I don't
like what they did in the first two so
that got a little repetitive for the
third time doing it they got away with
it so well in the second one but this
time it was just a little like okay I've
seen this cute but I've seen it though
my favorite part of the movie is
something we did in the first one and
it's where she goes by Clint Eastwood
they love
like how we went by Calvin Klein in the
first movie super funny so great I would
totally do the same thing he's like my
name's Eastwood Clint I've been like I'm
Portman Natalie or like cheese Rachel hi
Rachel I really liked when Marty can't
find black Smith Doc Brown so he goes to
the bar and he's like can I have a water
no no here's some whiskey and it's
smoking
ah mine doesn't smoke there is Yoda on
it though so he runs into West Biff or
what his name is Mad Dog I'm just gonna
call him if you could you know me just
know I'm talking about Mad Dog whatever
his name is when I say pit this scene is
really really well done I love like the
physicality of it the stunts they they
did were really awesome Marty does some
moonwalking that would make MJ proud
then they fling the tobacco spit on Biff
and Marty makes his amazing getaway like
on the chandelier and West Doc Brown
saves the day
something is super fun is seeing the
DeLorean being pulled by horses trying
to get it up to 88 miles an hour which
does not work but it's a great visual
and then they make the plan to have the
Train push the DeLorean to the 88 miles
and you need to go and then you meet
Clara who's Doc Brown's love interest my
love love love that he has a love
interest and I forget that actresses
name but she was amazing on 30 rock then
there at the town festival and the
costumes and sets are so fun I think is
an actor this would be the most fun to
work on and actually I was at Wizard
World Chicago two days after I saw the
first Back to the Future and I was with
awesome comic people um and they were
like let's go to this Back to the Future
fan I was like yeah great and we're
sitting there while what's like just
about to begin and I was like who's
actually gonna be here they were like
Christopher Lloyd and Michael J Fox and
I forgot her name the actress who plays
Marty's mom it was like what No
I was so excited uh I was definitely
also the only person in that room of
thousands of people who had recently
seen the film for the first time
everyone was like diehard fans usually
in the comments when people are like I
can't believe you've never seen this
you're disgrace I'm like whatever get
over it but in this room I was like I am
a disgrace I do deserve to be here
anyways the cast was saying that three
was their favorite one to work on though
it took the longest to do some of the
scenes also something that Michael J Fox
said was really great to hear and I
loved it now somebody came up and asked
a question and he was like I know that
there won't be any more sequels or
reboots but if there was who would you
want to play your own roles and all
three of them were like we would we
would want to play I would audition for
it again but Michael J Fox said that if
he didn't play that role and there was a
reboot he would want a girl to play it
and I thought that was awesome and
that's a perfect role for a girl totally
interchangeable I love it so another
thing at the festival when Doc and Clara
are adorably dancing Biff comes over and
steals her away and is really flipping
disgusting I can't say anymore because
of the fucking YouTube censorship things
but it's fucking gross
Marty saves doc from being shot and then
Biff calls Marty yellow and apparently
Marty can't handle being called anything
that is not offensive chicken and yellow
woo so Marty and Biff decide on a time
to kill each other and Biff is like
before 7:00 I like doing my killing
before breakfast and Marty is like after
8:00 I like doing my killing after
breakfast I'm like I wake up at 10 a.m.
so you guys are getting breakfast very
early so at this point in the movie doc
is super in love with Clara and
everything's right in the world and he
decides he's going to stay in the West
with her because love and then Marty's
like are you kidding me you're a
scientist he's like yeah okay I'll go
because science
kind of get both sides so when Doc Brown
tells Clara that he has to go and he
can't tell her where she's like if you
love me you should be able to tell me
where you're going it's like yeah fair
enough I'm a time traveler she slaps the
shit out of his face
and she's like that is the most
insulting degrading thing anyone's ever
said to me
like she has been hurt before so sad doc
has this incredible scene at the bar and
Christopher Lloyd is so good in this
scene he's so great in the whole entire
series but you really see that he loved
having this character arc with the love
in this movie and it's really fun and
sad to see him just really hurting and
he's really good and super sincere and
it's a it's a nice break from the
silliness of the movie but because doc
is so drunk from one shot theater Marty
has to fight this those were water so
Marty and Biff duel it's a cool scene he
uses his like metal shields as a frisbee
and he knocks him out and I love that
Marty doesn't drink anything or shoot
anyone in this movie I think it was like
an obvious conscious choice to have him
be like this like clean-cut dude I
appreciate that for this family film and
bib ends up in manure which is great for
the third time that was a repetitive to
me so I don't know what the mix is but
loved it so Marty and Doc make it on the
train and I love this scene they have to
hold it up to have access to it and
they're like stop the train and he's
like it's this a holdup but he's like
it's a science experiment and I gotta
say I would be more open to robbery if
it was for science it's a little bit
more then there's the very exciting
scene of them trying to get into the
DeLorean and they realize Clara's on
board doc saves Clara from the impending
doom of the train going off the tracks
but then he's gonna stay in the West Oh
No so Marty makes it back and doc and
Clara stay in the past and right when
Marty gets back there's the scene where
Ann
chill train is coming on the track so he
jumps out and the DeLorean is ruined
ruining any chance of seeing Doc Brown
again it's a really touching moment
actually having the DeLorean rune is
kind of oh this is the third and final
movie ah no it's a great final moment of
this amazing machine that caused these
incredible adventures and it's great
because doc wanted it to be would then
Jennifer the most pointless character in
all of existence shows up so they both
go back and he's telling her about the
adventure and they're looking at the
destroyed DeLorean and then a mother
flippin time-traveling train shows up
and it's so good yeah you get to see dog
road again it was so exciting
Claire is there and their children Jules
and burn oh I was legitimately tearing
up at this point in the movie so dog
Brown just pops in to say hello I'm okay
here's a picture of us because I love
you and I value your friendship and then
he's like I'm going and parties like are
you going to the Future he's like no I'd
already been there and then they pull up
into the air and this giant train is
shooting lasers out of it and they go
into what seems like space so he's
taking a train into space with his
family I don't know it's probably not
it's probably not right probably gonna
get a lot of comments telling me where
they're going because of conspiracy
theories and ideas I don't know guys I
honestly didn't expect to like this
trilogy as much as I did I grew up with
trilogies I guess I watched the original
Star Wars and Lord of the Rings and
Indiana Jones and this was a trilogy
that I was like I just got to get
through it I guess for the show for Tara
has ever seen I was not expecting to
love it as much as I did and it's it's
really wonderful that she Wendy please
don't ruin that door yeah I'm kind of
doing something oh well I didn't know
that
thanks for watching me watch these
movies with you guys I really appreciate
it and I'm excited to see what future
Tamra watches next well I just finished
watching all the land before times maybe
I'll start watching anime now
[Music]